in july of 1987 our mom filed four of us
kids in the car including John and Leigh
to take us on our annual summer vacation
in the wilderness of upstate New York
our parents have a small house up there
it's in the middle of nowhere about a
mile from the nearest neighbor to this
day cell phone reception does not exist
at that location as kids we spent our
time running out into the forest
creating our own adventures with no
adult supervision it was paradise we
spent our time playing in streams and
chasing frogs building forts all the
things that kids do and we wore mosquito
bites like a badge of honor because they
were the price we paid for absolute
freedom and it was an awesome experience
I consider us so lucky that we had the
opportunity to explore the natural world
at such a young age with no adult
supervision today 27 years later chris
and i both have kids in fact our
daughters are eight days apart we still
go to that same house in upstate New
York except now my mother our mother my
son mine too my son's grandmother is
deathly afraid of letting the grandkids
out of her sight why does my brother
have to remind her and I that at the
same age we too are running all over
those woods what has changed so
significantly in our family in less than
a generation and why do my kids now
experience a shrunken radius of play and
what does that change costing us in
terms of our kids character confidence
and creativity hi I'm Chris boggiano and
I'm John boggiano we're both parents
educators and lifelong learners it's two
dads who hope to raise happy and healthy
kids of our own we spent a lot of time
wondering what does that mean and what
can we actually do to make it happen
we've interacted with thousands of
students and parents educators and
innovators and today we want to share
with you some of what we found almost
everyone we've spoken to has expressed
the dismay
current state of American education and
almost all of their anxiety is related
to children's test scores while we don't
want to diminish diminish the importance
of test scores we think there's a
fundamentally overlooked factor of
success and that's a management of play
when we were kids the only toy in our
grandmother's house was a tub of Legos
that so far as I could tell had been
there since the beginning of time we
spent hundreds of hours playing with
those blocks throughout our childhood
because a tub of Legos that is an
invitation to imagine if play it fosters
children's social emotional and
intellectual skills by allowing them to
try out and master new things but even
today Legos have changed my son Julian
on several times his own body weight in
Legos
true however almost all of them look
like this they come in pre-scripted sets
with step-by-step instructions pre
imagined by somebody else he gets upset
at this Ninjago dragon loses even one
single piece where his two year old
cousin Olivia comes along and smashes it
on him or his sister I however get
excited when he builds this which is a
Star Destroyer made at a lego flat
plates and it's his imagination of what
it would look like on the inside and he
gets to play with this you see we
believe that the more play is a creation
of children's minds their own minds the
more that they are authors of their own
identity the more powerful it is and
it's regardless of whether they're the
screen writer or the scientist the ninja
warrior or the princess but when we say
play a lot of parents end up thinking
playdates but we believe that playdates
can beat a childhood what microwave
dinner is to food seemingly healthy
well-intentioned highly refined and it
turns out that when you look a little
closer they're totally devoid of any
nutritional value the subtle shift
towards structured play can strip away
the spontaneity creativity and curiosity
they're all natural elements of healthy
childhood development for the nba's in
the crowd try to think about a pack of
kids just running around outside of no
adult supervision that's like a life
internship it requires all the things
you pay money to come to Stanford to
learn strategy negotiations probably
even some interpersonal dynamics safety
and success these are fundamental to the
mindset of today's parents so let's
start with safety whether it's because
of the 24-hour cable news the internet
or Amber Alerts today's parents are
deathly afraid that there is a child
predator around every corner parents
have always wanted their kids to be safe
but today there's a pervasive anxiety
and it's affecting our kids we've tried
talking to parents about statistics
would show that we live in the safest
times on modern record however it
doesn't matter in my
self included every one of us would say
better safe than sorry so how do we
balance the benefits of imaginative play
with concern for our children safety
this is where the radius comes in rather
than a narrow path or a checklist
defining success let's imagine a wide
radius or a boundary and within that
boundary we should give our kids free
rein to imagine create and explore their
own worlds so let me be clear
imaginative play is not anarchy it does
not mean there are no rules it's a
healthy part of childhood development
I'm not asking you to run out of here
and find the nearest six-year-old and
give them some matches scissors and
superglue and let them see what he can
come up boundaries are the line between
safety and recklessness the boundary for
your ten-month-old might be the walls of
her pack and play and the boundary for
your ten-year-old might be the area
between your house and its best friend's
house all the way down the street
success the other fundamental factor
every parent wants their kids to be
successful however parents in society
today are increasingly defining success
as the narrow path that leads through
the elite college admissions process
some of this is related to the shrinking
family size our grandmother was one of
seven children our father was one of
four today one or two is more common the
benefits of fewer children are that more
parental time and energy can be spent on
each individual kit the downside the
downside is the paralyzing fear that
your perfect six-year-old won't get into
Stanford we hold their own kids hostage
to our own hope so much so that won't
let them risk failure get in trouble you
want to know a secret we spoke with the
folks in the Stanford admissions office
guess what they reject sixty-nine
percent of applicants with perfect s80
scores and you know what else do you
know what they told us they're looking
for in their perfect applicant
in their own words it's someone who has
found his or her own voice so what does
that it means that they're looking for
people who aren't relying on Stanford to
define who they are so how do we help
kids find their own voice imaginative
play on structured activities creative
freedom that's the key to building
character confidence and creativity as
parents I encourage you to think about
why boundaries rather than narrow roads
and precise checklists boundaries give
us permission to both keep kids safe and
allow them to become authors of their
own identity as a parent myself I would
love it if my kids could come to
Stanford if that's what they wanted to
do however I also realized that if I
push them too hard and predefined
success for them in too much of a
certain way I am likely to cause their
failure or hinder their chances of
getting it so my challenge as a parent
is to help my kids find their own voice
and our challenge as a society is to
give our kids the space to develop
within their own radius of play thank
you very much
you